- Let's close out with one
last story to warm your heart.
This is What I'm Liking.
(jazzy music begins)
(audience applauds)
March is women's history
month, making it a great time
to celebrate female first's
across this country.
That's why I wanna tell
you about Emily Harrington.
Not long ago, she became the first woman
to free climb the golden gate route
of El Capitan in under 24 hours.
I couldn't do it in 24 years.
Cool.
(audience laughs)
This is a serious feat, people.
She scaled nearly... it's
the nearly perpendicular
3,200 foot rock face in Yosemite
in 21 hours and 14 minutes.
(audience claps)
What?
With just a rope for safety.
I'd need a helicopter to fly me there.
We have Emily on the line right now.
What's up Emily?
(audience applauds)
- Hey there, how are you?
- You are so impressive,
I'm gonna lead with that.
I mean, you pulled off
just such an insane thing.
Has this been a dream of yours?
- Yes, I've been climbing
since I was 10 years old.
Everything from climbing competitions
to climbing Mount Everest
but this goal in particular
really challenged me
in the most inspiring and difficult way.
I spent years practicing and
training to get to this point.
When you climb El Cap, El Capitan,
the hardest part is
actually at the very end.
So I like to tell people that
it's like running a marathon
and then running your
fastest hundred meters
at the very, very end.
So it presents this huge
endurance challenge.
During a previous attempt, I
actually had a really bad fall.
I wound up in the hospital
with a concussion.
So there's a lot of failure and struggle
but eventually I was successful.
(audience claps)
- Oh my gosh.
So I mean, I can only imagine
but how did you feel when you said,
it's a historic record you
just said, how did that feel?
- I think it was...
it was more a combination
of relief and joy
but there was also this sadness
and realizing that this process was over.
I mean, I spent years
focused on this one thing
and then all of a sudden, it was finished.
But honestly, you know, it's
just one part of my career.
I feel like I have a lot more to come.
I'm really excited to try
other routes on El Capitan
as well as travel the world
and continue to climb
things that inspire me.
- I was gonna say like,
what's your next thing?
Do you have, what would
you like to do next?
Do you know yet or are you
still thinking about it?
- I'm still thinking about
it at, it's up in the air.
There's a lot harder
routes on El Cap itself
and then there's big
walls all over the world.
I actually just went to Kurdistan
and climbed a big wall there.
I'm going to Baffin Island,
which is up near the Arctic circle.
So there's quite a bit to do.
- I love that your like, hobby and passion
takes you to so many cool places
that you might have
never visited otherwise,
that's really cool.
I'm liking your post right now, Emily.
We think you're awesome
and that's not... you look like a warrior!
I mean, you just look
badass, let's just be real.
That's not all though, our
season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor ultimate overachievers.
I can't imagine anyone that deserves this
more than you right now in this moment.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars, how's that sound?
(audience applauds)
- Wow, thank you!
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] Thank you so much, Emily!
Good luck on your next climb.